[Musique]
m
l'un stiegler bonsoir vous recevons pour
une chaîne internet qui s'appelle singer
view on diffuse en direct
actuellement on vous reçoit parce que
vous êtes un philosophe et on a remarqué
que vous vous intéressiez profondément
au sujet qu'on peut traiter depuis des
années comme l'économie les médias et
tout un tas de choses y compris
l'éducation et surtout le web comment
allez-vous pas trop mal
disons en fait il m'arrive de dire mal
comme tout le monde mais voilà ça
pourrait être pire
on attaque dans le dur direct
médiacratie
ce que vous pouvez nous en dire votre
état des lieux et les perspectives
futures de du dispositif qui nous est
imposée au condamné c'est cher
c'est un vaste sujet ça va ce sujet
qu'il faut maintenant
comment dire
quand il faut faire une histoire qui
commence à être lent qu'en fait
voilà je veux pas je perds va exposer
des choses que j'ai jugé que j'ai me
présenter dans divers travaux depuis les
15 dernières années disons que
j'ai publié deux textes je crois
qui parle spécifiquement de
de l'apparition de ce que j'ai appelé
dans le deuxième c'est dire la
télécratie
et ensuite j'ai publié des choses sur
les braises mais les médias numériques
disant technologies numériques et c'est
une autre page tmg répondront de temps à
cette question
le premier temps ces voix là qu'est ce
que c'est que qu'est-ce qui est sec
l'origine de ce que vous appelez la
médiacratie
que j'ai appelé moi la télécratie
c'est d'abord le fait que le capitalisme
consumériste qui se met en place au
début du 20e siècle aux états unis
suppose de canaliser le désir des
individus et de le réorienter vers les
marchandises donc en fait de le détruire
en réalité parce que les marchands
disent à ce désir pas ça se consomme et
le désir si jamais une consommation les
gens qu'on désire on les consomme pas on
les soigne on est on leur fait l'amour
éventuellement me suis pas de la
consommation
tandis que les objets que l'on consomme
on et désire parler détruits au
contraire donc voilà est aujourd'hui
évidemment nous constatons que cette
destruction des objets que c'est la
destruction du monde en totalité en fait
voilà c'est pas simplement la discussion
des objets ou des sujets qui les
consomment ça ça commence dans les
années 20 aux états unis
à travers le développement de ce qu'on
va appeler les industries culturelles ce
que les philosophes adorno horkheimer
appellerons en 1944 les industries
culturelles etc mis en oeuvre par un
type qui a neveu de sigmund freud et qui
dit
voilà si on veut développer une
industrie de la consommation veut faire
consommer des choses aux gens qu'ils
n'ont pas besoin de ces choses là il
faut les matraques et les canaliser
actives et les plus houleux du primaire
dans mon cerveau est d'abord d'abord
canaliser leur attention
au début c'est pas complètement
pulsionnel ça va le devenir
c'est relativement tardive d'ailleurs le
venir pulsionnel d'abord le hollywood
par exemple c'est une machine à sublimer
au départ disons à travers à travers des
récits édifiants comme j'ai pas john
fort nous voilà et pendant longtemps
quand même les médias américains
conservent une certaine
certaine comment dire
certains autres retient de
l'idéalisation et du désir mais
effectivement ça va devenir alors
d'abord ça va détruire les capacités
à produire de dire qu'est ce que c'est
que le désir ça mérite comme une petite
explication pour beaucoup de gens le
désir s'est passée la pulsion justement
c'est par exemple les penchants sexuels
de monsieur strauss kahn ou des trucs
comme ça ça c'est pas du tout le désir
ça c'est la pulsion le désir c'est pas
la pulsion c'est de la pulsion
transformé nous avons toutes les
pulsions
mais nos désirs consiste à transformer
nos pulsions en investissement
investissement dans la vie avec une
personne dans la société voilà c'est ce
que fera une appelle parfois la
sublimation et donc le désir s'il a pu
changer une chose je désire c'est autre
chose et frais y explique d'un texte de
1923 qui s'appelle le mois et le ca que
pour transformer les pulsions désir il
faut éduquer les pulsions il faut voilà
faut transmettre
tout un processus qui s'opèrent en
général d'abord dans la relation entre
l'enfant et son milieu familial et puis
ensuite la société et
tout ce processus d'apprentissage à
transformer ses pulsions en
investissement qui est fondamental pour
la société eh bien c'est ce que les
industries culturelles vont un peu
détruire parce que plus qu'un peu
qu'elles vont totalement détruire la fin
pourquoi parce que les industries
culturelles vont se substituer
progressivement à toutes ses relations
sociales
qui jusqu'àlors mme constituaient ces
processus d'apprentissage
l'investissement social par exemple
l'université du maryland a publié une
enquête toucher un plus exactement comme
ce tome les années 2000 qui a montrait
alors d'abord l'université marie lang a
suivi quarante mille familles pendant
trente ans quarante mille familles de
téléspectateurs ils ont montré que
c'était les spectateurs en fait étaient
tous d'accord pour dire qu'il était
accro la télévision qu'ils entendaient
totalement que ça va être totalement
détruit leur leur vie familiale que par
exemple les parents les enfants n'ont
pratiquement plus de discussions et
qu'ils étaient incapables de se passer
désormais 2 de cela et qu'ils étaient
profondément déprimé c'est intéressant
si l'année 2000 et c'est l'expression de
ce que je viens d'alizée mois donc dans
un deuxième aucun appel la télécratie
contre la démocratie je voulais c'est de
montrer que
ce qu'on appelle les médias de masse
massifie les gens justement et j'ai
aussi parlé de ce à partir d'une figure
tristement célèbre qui s'appelle richard
d'urle qui est un type qui avait
assassiné des gens pistolet mitrailleur
et et les conseillers municipaux de
notaire voilà et je m'étais intéressé à
lui parce que voilà en lisant le journal
j'avais découverte qu'il l'avait journal
intime et dans ce journal intime il
expliquait qu'il était un grand
consommateur de toutes les visions et
aussi qu'il avait perdu le sentiment
d'exister et que pour vivre pour avoir
le sentiment dans ça c'est lui qui a
écrit ça pour avoir une fois lance dans
ma vie le sentiment d'exister je vais
devoir faire du mal et quinze jours
après il m'a sa recrue huit personnes
ils ont ils en blesse 15
ce type là à la fin j'ai fait un petit
livre sur lui et à la fin du bouquin
jeudi il ya des millions de richard dur
de la fête est donc lui il est passé à
l'acte y en a plein qui passent pas à
l'acte mais ça pourrait changer voilà
alors depuis ça s'est bien aggravé quand
même la massification du cheptel parce
que c'est une massification d'un cheptel
est ce que la masse critique a pas été
dépassée est ce que il est possible de
revenir en arrière
réhabiliter l'esprit critique de jean
basset c'est possible parce que c'est
indispensable
je n'y arrive alors est ce qu'il faut
appeler l'esprit critique des gens oui
mais ça passe par beaucoup d'autres
choses le processus cognitif des
analyses du monde de deer et
d'intelligence oil and intelligence pas
revenir sur le concept intelligent
individuelles et collectives mai
oui c'est possible parce qu'on n'a pas
le choix et même maintenant c'est pas du
tout sûr qu'on y voit là c'est possible
mais c'est pas mais c'est pas certain il
est même plutôt très certain qu'on n'y
arrivera pas si on prend les données
objectives si on voit l'évolution
récente au cours des dix dernières
années
trump et tous ces trucs là on peut se
dire on est sur une tante irrattrapable
bon moi je pense que les situations
critiques sont toujours ce qui se
présente comme une pente irrattrapable
et qu'il faut toujours essayer de
rattraper la situation puis voilà on
verra bien alors là pour répondre à la
question faut parler des médias
numériques
parce que bon mois les intérêts qu'on a
en commun ils viennent d'abord de
l'intérêt pour le web et les algorithmes
et toutes les technologies depuis très
longtemps
mais je me suis intéressé en particulier
utilisez un 90 puisque le web et à paris
dans les années 90 le chien chat c'est
aussi les logiciels libres et ce qui
m'est apparu très clairement comme à des
millions de gens dans le monde c'était
que ces réseaux la ouvrait une
possibilité tout à fait nouvelle 2d
massification
de reconstruction va justement d'une des
choses collectives d'une réhabilitation
des singularités etc etc bref d'une
possibilité de rupture avec l'époque qui
avait produit richard durnez ce genre de
et ce genre de misère
et j'y ai cru longtemps et j'y crois
toujours d'ailleurs mais en même temps
depuis son passé pas mal de choses parce
que ça c'était les années 90 j'étais
donc il ya plus de vingt ans
le web a été rendu accessible au public
en 1993 donc les 25 ans et est bien le
web était totalement dénaturé et pendant
longtemps il a permis ce que vous faites
sur cette chaîne
moi j'ai fait aussi des choses comme ça
pas avec des entretiens vidéo
systématiquement mais avec industrialis
on a créé un site aussi qu'il y avait
beaucoup beaucoup d'abonnés commencé à
les embêter radio pirate un oui oui est
ce le seul processus bon il a été rendu
possible par percer par ces réseaux
corses quand nous avons fait nous assène
australie ça me donnait en avec 40000
personnes qui suivaient richesse on a
beaucoup moins maintenant mais puisqu'on
a investi dans d'autres maintenant dans
d'autres questions mais on faisait ça
sans un centime fait c'était totalement
et moi je connais assez bien
l'audiovisuel j'ai été directeur de
l'ina pendant quelques années par
exemple cette petite caméra que j'ai sur
mon smartphone chez peugeot les mimes et
voilà pour avoir l'équivalent en caméra
numérique dans 96 à linas étaient 250
mille francs
aujourd'hui c'est une fonction gratis en
quelques sorte que mon téléphone donc il
ya une incroyable transformation
c'est incroyable trois formations
auraient dû amener l'europe va
développer une toute nouvelle politique
des industries culturelles de
l'éducation etc elle ne l'a pas fait et
donc les investissements que l' effet
dans le web ont été récupérés dans la
silicon valley qui total 4 totalement
dénaturé tout ça parce que à partir de
2007 2008 le smartphone d'une part le
réseau social d'autres tares façon
facebook et bien a totalement changé
vous l'avez creuser pourquoi l'europe
l'a pas fait c'est politique culturelle
parce que pour vous c'est dû à des
pressions nord américaine du show comme
si je dirais due à une crétinisation de
l'europe par le lobbying américain
c'est un sujet que je connais bien parce
que j'ai été pas lobbyistes exactement à
bruxelles may fages quand j'étais à
l'ina joie présentait les intérêts
français dans l'audiovisuel vu depuis la
puissance publique française disons que
j'ai participé à des allées groupe
d'élaboration de ce qu'on appelait le
pcrd à l'époque si notre programme cadre
de recherche et de développement bon et
j'ai vu comme tous les gens qui
connaissent un peu bruxelles le nom de
deux lobbyistes
anglais ou américains qui sont installés
là-bas qui explique exactement qu'il ne
faut pas faire ci qu'il faut pas faire
ça et c est qui explique exactement
qu'il ne faut pas faire ce que
l'amérique fait mais ne dit pas parce
que par exemple
j'avais publié cette note puisque quand
j'étais directeur de l'ina j'étais en
charge des notes au gouvernement sur le
visuel s'affalait les études d'audience
et partie de mes attributions
et donc j'avais fait une note la journée
en reprenant une étude d'ailleurs d'un
américain qui s'appelle schiller qui
montrait que l'armée américaine avait
investi mille milliards de dollars dans
le multimédia en 20 ans et donc pendant
ce temps là les américains dit zahia il
faut pas que la puissance publique
s'occupe de voir une politique
industrielle c'est le marché qui doit
tout faire mais en amérique c'est pas du
tout le marché google par exemple n'est
pas sorti du marché il n'y avait pas de
marché pour google juste et ce google
s'est sorti de 50 ans d'investissement
de l'américaine dans les technologies de
l'information de la de l'âme de la la
notation des liens hypertextes etc etc
et donc il ya une niaiserie
européenne qui est absolument
stupéfiante qui comprend rien du tout
parce que c'est un dessin c'est
simplement une bande de crétins n'ont
cessé ces pas à dessein parce que les
gens ne sont pas bêtes par par volonté
je dirais que ça par lâcheté mais c'est
aussi
du fait qu'
il y a une
capacité de storytelling en amérique du
nord absolument inouïe qui a été une
énorme investissement depuis edward
bernays ce délire depuis 1917 puisque
c'est en 1917 que bernès à a lancé cette
vision qui passait par les théories de
son oncle sigmund freud très bon bouquin
leur propagande 1 voilà c'est propaganda
en particulier et
les européens n'ont rien compris à tout
ça moi j'avais été très frappé une année
c'était il ya longtemps maintenant
peut-être quinze ans j'écoutais une
émission de france culture à matin
l'invité c'était michel rocard
est la personne qu'il interviewait lui
avait demandé mais alors est-ce qu'il
faut une politique culturelle européenne
il ya non surtout pas faut - laisser aux
états quelque chose qui leur est propre
et c'est la culture il avait absolument
rien compris parce que ce qu'elle fait
toute la stratégie de développement des
états unis c'est un débat en 1912 au
sénat américain qui est quel est le sens
du cinéma quelques l important soit
accordée au cinéma et un sénateur dit la
chose définitive il dit le cinéma c'est
le commerce try to follow ce film si on
a une industrie du cinéma on contrôlera
la consommation la production et c'est
ce qu'ils ont fait et dire au moment où
lourd car disait ça j'avais reçu j'étais
directeur l'ircam à l'époque j'avais
reçu une délégation de coréens du sud
qui disait on va développer une
industrie culturelle coréenne excellent
c'était des investissements publics
parce qu'il faut ce sont des s'est pas
directement le marché c'est ce qui rend
possible les marchés donc c'est en amont
des marchés ces deux là
la méta économie c'est celui d'hier et
aux états unis ce qui fait cette
politique c'est l'armée américaine je
dis pas qu'il faut forcément passer par
l'armée d'ailleurs il ya par des armées
européennes c'est une des spécificités
de l'europe qui la rend peut-être peu
crédible
mais en tout cas voilà qu'est ce qu'est
ce qui permet aux états unis de l'armée
américaine de faire ces investissements
c'est que l'armée c'est ce qu'ils
considéraient stratégie que c'est à dire
c'est en dehors de tout cadre ordinaire
c'est la production protection de la
nation donc ça permet aux états unis
d'avoir d'énormes d'énormes capacités de
recherche voilà qui sont finement moi
moi même j'ai eu des financements
d'armes américaines je check in q tel
j'arrivais pas à faire financer des
travaux sur des réseaux sociaux
alternatifs mrc la marine américaine
celle l'us navy d'études ses services
secrets lui à ce navire qui ont financé
de post doc chez moi et c'est absolument
incroyable j'arrivais pas à obtenir un
centime de l'état français ou de
l'europe voilà et donc
voilà on l'europe est totalement
crétiniser en fait sur ces questions et
si ça dure elle disparaîtra enfin je
veux dire elle deviendra une
voie là il va y avoir la grande
puissance chinoise
d'autres puissances asiatiques
périphériques l'inde en particulier qui
est en pleine croissance
peut-être l'amérique probablement
l'amerique maintiendra
une puissance économique très importante
pendant encore longtemps même si à mon
avis elle deviendra elle passera
derrière la chine d'ailleurs il ya des
gens qui disent qu déjà fait que c'est
déjà fait
mais l'europe peut disparaître dans
cette affaire garde le roi peut devenir
le lieu de destination les touristes
chinois ou américains
d'ailleurs dans ma rue il ya plein
d'américains qui habite au coeur de
paris parce que c'est le rêve de tous
les américains fortunés d'avoir un de
vivre à paris et voilà l'europe risque
de devenir ça c'est ne se ressaisit pas
et c'est très très mal partis quand même
très mal partis
les politiques je vais vous dire
proactive pour se réapproprier sa est ce
que vous comprenez que ça crée des
mouvements ça renforcer le front
national ce repli identitaire
cette demande d'un kaiser qui a été fait
aux états unis avec trump qui a été fait
en europe qui a été fait au japon avec
ab est ce que le fait qu'on soit des
cultures is et si je peux dire ça crée
des extrêmes
bien entendu de toute façon ce qui
créait ses comportements
réactif réactionnaire
régressif et cetera c'est la souffrance
d'abord les gens souffrent énormément
partout souvent ils le déni d'ailleurs
ça passait pas vraiment pas bien du tout
extraits énormément de gens qui vont mal
mais ils veulent pas l'admettre parce
que parce que voilà ils sont pas
capables d'assumer cette pourtant été
moins qui vont mal et ou de suicides
réussis vermine toute consommation de
bridge de chiens de toutes là toute la
place à mme thomas théologie le démontre
de manière extrêmement claire
fait en amérique c'était un des sujets
de la campagne électorale comment lutter
contre la toxine la lame la consommation
d'héroïne
de masse en russie aussi à utiliser
si son assise grâce à ou dit la
diminution des taux de suicide les des
consommations de drogues et ainsi de
suite alors tout ça est produit par quoi
notamment parce que je décrivais la
pauvre richard john parce que c'est pour
ça qu'il ya des millions de références
dur richardson qui souffrait c'est ce
qui la rend du méchant en fait c'est sa
souffrance mois méchants et les
criminels mais
il ya toutes sortes voilà deux saisons
de de causalité psychologique pour ça
comme ça psychologiquement
mais après il ya aussi d'autres raisons
nous sommes dans ce qu'on a appelé la
mondialisation
moi j'appelle ça lit mondialisation et
la mondialisation c'est pas une
mondialisation c'est une globalisation
pourquoi je dis que c'est une pas une
mondialisation parce que le qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un monde bat un monde
c'est une réalité consistante tous les
ans entre qu'ils appartiennent à quelque
chose à quoi ils tiennent etc
c'est pas moi si on va est
extraordinairement fera témoin par le
sud du maroc en dessous du en dessous du
de l'atlas mme à la limite dans la
vallée du dadès la limite du sahara
express est un monde là c'est un monde
il ya des gens qui sont magnifiques
paysages extraordinaires etc mais il ya
ça devient très très difficile d'avoir
le sentiment d'être dans un monde voilà
c'est plus un monde dans lequel nous
sommes c'est ni monde lassé de l'immonde
ses dunes au monde alors qu'est ce que
jacques le monde eh bien c'est ce qui
produit de la localité
la localité depuis des dizaines d'années
c'est devenu tabou parce que si on dit
moi j'ai par exemple j'adore la corse et
j'aime de la localité de corse et je
soutiens les indépendantistes corses
quand je dis ça quand je dis que les
soutes et 1 c'est d'ailleurs pas les
indépendantistes que je soutiens ces les
autonomistes voilà mais je comprends
très bien les les autonomistes et les
indépendantistes en reçoit donc tu as
qu'ils ont un pays une culture
absolument fantastique je connais très
très bien fait culture j'ai vécu
beaucoup en corse or sud beaucoup d'amis
encore sur tournoi
bruce wayne julies mais je connais bien
que j'ai déjà là et c'est un pays
extraordinaire
évidemment le côté extraordinaire les
côtés traître est aussi très très
comment dire insupportable parfois là il
ya une réelle xénophobie etc ça c'est
une réalité enfin c'est la réalité des
insulaires en général tu vois là c'est
compliqué mais en tout cas ce que je
veux dire c'est que
la localité c'est mal c'est mal portée
aujourd'hui c'est pas politiquement
correct et ça c'est connoté nationaliste
front national et ses acteurs mais c'est
pas vrai du tout c'est pas vrai du tout
la localité s'est pas du tout
nécessairement nationalistes ou front
national la localité c'est la condition
de la vie
si on prend les sciences l'éducation on
étudie les sciences en particulier la
physique et la biologie du 20e siècle
les processus physiques sont des
processus anthropique qui sont
universels entre piques voulant dire
étant emportés par dans la dissipation
d'énergie par l'augmentation du désordre
c'est à dire vers la mort thermique de
l'univers pour dire dans le langage de
l'astrophysique ja vivent donc la vie
serait la quintessence même de cette
fonction car dissipe énormément
d'énergie c'est ça oui mais en même
temps localement elles luttent contre la
dissipation d'énergie qu'est ce que
c'est qu'un être vivant ben vous et moi
là nous sommes à 37° presse sauf si nous
avons la grippe nous sommes à 38 39 ou
si nous sommes vieux nous sommes à 36 et
quand nous arrivons à 35 900 morts donc
il ya un gradient à l'intérieur duquel
on se trouve voilà qui est l'acte ampera
tueur moyenne d'invertébrés supérieur
que nous sommes autour de 37° nous
gardons l'énergie nous en sortir tout à
l'heure il fait pas très froid
aujourd'hui mais j'ai pas très chaud non
plus là
si on sort à poil on va avoir vie de
froid
donc on a des habits pour conserver
l'énergie les animaux n'ont pas
d'habitants des fourrures ou des des
poils voilà et qu'est ce que c'est qu'un
être vivant c'est une localité qui
maintient un certain ordre
thermique métaboliques
chimiques etc et cet ordre on appelle ça
le neg entrepris en appel c'est un ordre
cet organisme une organisation un
organisme en tant qu'être humain qui
développe une capacité à différer
l'entreprise entre pc la loi l'univers
ça on le sait depuis le 19e siècle mais
les êtres vivants et une capacité à
différer cette loi pas éternel par
exemple nous mourrons aujourd'hui aux
alentours de 80 ans bon il ya deux
siècles c'était plutôt aux alentours de
35 ou 40 ans en moyenne les éléphants
vivent plus longtemps les tortues encore
plus longtemps mais tous les êtres
vivants meurent
parce que ils sont localement et
temporairement n'est qu'entre pire
qu'ils peuvent lutter contre l'
entrepris un certain temps puis à un
moment donné ils n'en peuvent plus
l'entropie gagne himeur nous sommes tous
voués à mourir mais
ce qui m'importe dans cette affaire à 7
souligné que l'année contre pis c'est la
vie mais que l'un d'entre eux paient
toujours le local et qu'elle est liée à
ce qu'on appelle par exemple en écologie
des niches et ce sont des localités un
monde humain c'est une façon de produire
l'année d'entropie par les voix qui sont
pas seulement biologique mais qui sont
appelons les techniques artistiques
culturelles et ses langues linguistique
symbolique
éducationnel religieuses de toutes
sortes de dimensions de de cette
production de quoi c'est plus la
biodiversité comme d'environ puisque ce
que je décrivais sur lyon ça engendre ce
qu'on appelle la biodiversité c'est
extraordinaire variabilité quand on se
rapproche de l'équateur c'est absolument
inouïe la variabilité des formes des
couleurs des textures etc le vivant en
produits qu'on est en train de détruire
en ce moment à très grande vitesse
sixième extinction de masse voilà
annoncé maintenant mais c'est plus
qu'une annonce est un processus qui est
enclenché et qui est probablement
irréversible d'ailleurs malheureusement
c'est trop tard on le change et on
pourra diminuer les faits mais ne pourra
pas éviter
la disparation de masse parce qu'elle
est très profondément engagé mais c'est
pas simplement une destruction la no
deal de la biodiversité si une
destruction de l'anneau au diversité
qu'est ce que c'est que landreau
diversité c'est l'intelligence
et pourquoi est-ce que trump et là c'est
le crétin mondiale
que tout le monde voit comme un crétin
même stratégie de l'homme fou
c'est pas une stratégie trame chez un
symptôme
il ya sûrement évidemment une stratégie
je souligne un point important qui
mettent des sous nice signalé par un ami
italien était philosophe il ya quelqu'un
qui a parlé donald trump en
1987 c'était félix guattari
dans un livre s'appelle les trois
écologies il dit il ya un mec s'appelle
donald trump
investisseurs immobiliers il l'a déjà
intéressés absolument incroyable
philosophe parfois c'est pas ça sert à
quelque chose c'est à quelque chose
qui est rompue maintenant
trump c'est l'incarnation de ce don
cheval
la destruction de l'anneau diversité
c'est de l'intelligence et la carnation
de la bêtise la bêtise qui dirigent le
monde part qui demande un
bordel pas la mégalomanie qui dirige le
monde
toute façon c'est une forme de la bêtise
la mégalomanie mai mais je dirais pas
donc c'est la mégalomanie bien sûr que
iliad est évidemment il ya des tendances
mégalomaniaque chez tous ces gens là
tous les puissants qui sont qui sont
en position effectivement de pouvoir oui
bien sûr il ya cette eau peut appeler ça
la volonté de puissance on peut appeler
ça de deux mille manières mais je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on a affaire un processus
de l'appel salade hainaut et isation un
oasis andrex à venir la pensée et on est
dans un processus de destruction de la
pensée qui est extrêmement grave parce
que qu'est-ce que c'est que la fonction
de la pensée je prends le vos fonctions
au sens de philosophe anglais qui
s'appelait lewaï tu vois là et qui dit
la raison ça une fonction
bien ça ça pour fonction de lutter
contre 3 pied justement pas comme les
animaux les animaux luttent contre eux
entre autres pim et en pensant
simplement en exécutant les lois de la
biologie
c'est la biologie dans le monde animal
la biologiste qui régit les rapports
entre les cellules les organes les
organismes etc et c'est une
c'est une loi si je puis dire qu'ils
s'appliquent inéluctablement tous les
organismes vivants qui devait inspecter
y compris à nous en tant que nous sommes
des êtres vivants mais
chez l'homme il y a une autre dimension
qui n'est pas lié par les organes
que l'on appelle en automatique c'est à
dire biologique et on regarde notre
corps et les organes internes de notre
corps il ya la dimension des organes
artificiels le micro dans lequel je suis
en train de parler il est la plus
touchée est jeune il faut pas que j'y
touche les caméras qui sont en train de
me filmer mais aussi la veste que je
porte les lunettes etc tout ça ce sont
des organes exo somatiques et ses
organes l'exo somatiques et bien ils
produisent un autre type de
diversification qui n'est pas la
biodiversité qu'on pourrait appeler ça
la techno diversité qui produit la
diversité des cultures parce que la
techno diversité c'est pas forcément
apple ou je ne sais quoi c'est aussi les
silex taillés de
17 règlement c'est une société de
transformance et sa
une société de transformer il la met à
naître qui produit en permanence des
organes nouveau donc kiwis se
transforment effectivement pourquoi
parce que les organes qu'il a déjà
produit provoque des effets pervers donc
il est obligé pour lutter contre les
effets pervers de produire de nouveaux
organes qui vont venir compenser les
effets pervers mais qui ont créé
d'autres effets pervers c'est très très
bien décrit sa part cygwin frei dans un
texte appelle malaise dans la culture
ou par exemple freund y a le téléphone
c'est génial je peux joindre mon fils se
téléphone tous ah bon à l'époque de fred
c'est encore récent la version du
téléphone ah oui mais en même temps
c'est parce qu'elle téléphone qu'il est
parti qu'on essaie par ex donc voilà
freud montrent que en fait c'est les
organes que j'appelle exo somatiques les
organes artificiels
en fait on toujours un double côté une
dimensions c'est ce qu'on appelle dans
l'association furent au bout oui mais
c'est aussi ce qu'on appelle le
pharmakon voilà le fait que tout
artifice et toujours à la fois quelque
chose qui apporte des possibilités
curative c'est-à-dire bénéfique si on
veut parler simplement et aussi des
éléments de toxicité voilà des paires du
transhumanisme ça vous fait résonner ah
bah oui j'en parle beaucoup du
transhumanisme enfin j'en parle beaucoup
est ce que c est ce que c'est là
l'ultime fonction de la mégalomanie pour
s'affranchir de cette fonction
anthropique
alors ça c'est ce qui c'est ce qui
constitue le discours de ceux qu'on
appelle les extras obtient qui
prétendent à travers le transhumanisme
échappé à l'entreprise parce
qu'évidemment une insanité
échappé à l'entropie bon prix d'un
discours qui anciens d'ailleurs
mais après le transhumanisme voix qu'est
ce que c'est que j'ai fait j'ai consacré
un colloque autant si munitions l'année
dernière au centre pompidou né et j'ai
pas mal travaillé dessus c'est du
storytelling de marketing stratégique à
l'échelle planétaire au moment de ce que
j'appelle le passage à la société exo
sphérique qu'est ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire que
nous vivons dans ce que vladimir
vernadski en 1926 a appelé la biosphère
excuses avec la biosphère la biosphère
c'est ce qui se trouve entre la
lithosphère l'atmosphère la lithosphère
c'est donc la grippe touche juste
pendant croûte terrestre et la croûte
terrestre dios et c'est le socle rocheux
voilà lithos pierre grecque et
l'atmosphère
c'est
la couche d'oxygène disons grosso modo
qui entoure la terre sous la
stratosphère et il y as entre
l'atmosphère et la lithosphère
la biosphère qu'est ce que c'est que la
biosphère si la petite couche vivable
autour de la planète où on trouve les
êtres vivants
ces êtres vivants
qui sont apparus il ya quelques
milliards d'années déjà n'ya pas très
très longtemps après l'apparition de la
terre en fait la création de la terre
c'est un milliard et demi 2 milliard
d'années après l'apparition de la terre
ces êtres vivants qui sont d'abord des
êtres extrêmement l'iman terre
ils vont provoquer les transformations
chimiques en captant l'énergie solaire
et en transformant le carbone à travers
notamment à travers l'énergie solaire et
ils vont produire dès que ce que vers la
ce qu'ils appellent des synthèses
biochimiques qui vont faire apparaître
pariant sur la terre des minéraux qu'on
trouve pas ailleurs parce que ce sont
des minéraux qui sont générés par
l'activité du vivant et le calcaire par
exemple et nous sommes ici dans le
bassin parisien nous sommes sur une
couche de quelqu'un mais ce calcaire ce
sont des coquillages accumulé en fait au
fil des dd
des milliers d'années est en fait le
vivant produit énormément de la
d'activité biochimiques qui fait
apparaître de nouveaux types de
molécules et c'est
ça c'est la biosphère tels que cours de
3 milliards d'années elle va évoluer et
verdun ce qui va faire une histoire de
cette évolution mais nous nous vivons
lorsque certains appellent maintenant la
technosphère
qu'est-ce qui se passe il ya trois
millions d'années c'est très très
récemment à cette échelle trois
milliards d'années est apparu un être
vivant qui produit des organes exo
somatiques
ses organes qui sont d'abord du silex
taillés ensuite vont se complexifier de
plus en plus et depuis 250 ans ils sont
devenus industriels ce sont des usines
ce sont des machines à vapeur ou autre
ou électrique ou à combustion à
explosion et cetera
et tout ça va produire ce qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui l'anthropocène qu'est ce que
c'est que l'anthropocène et bien c'est
ce qui en ce moment est en train de
produire une transformation de la
biosphère où vous avez par exemple -
j'enseigne en chine amazon livre en
chine
amazon livre en amérique amazon livre en
europe amazon lire d'ailleurs des
bouquins que je commande le matin y'en a
ils ont été tiré à 1000 exemplaires et
bien il arrive à me livrer le soir même
à l'échelle de la planète il arrive à
livrer le soir même un bouquin un mec
qui l'a commandé alors qu'il a été tiré
à 1000 exemplaires ce qu'a pu m'en
inouïe et ça c'est la puissance de
calcul les algorithmes ça c'est ce qui
fait que nous sommes entrés aujourd'hui
dans un âge de la biosphère qui tout à
fait nouveau très très très différent de
tout ce qui était connue jusque par
exemple à l'époque de la philosophie des
lumières
comment réagissent les élites face un
set
cet épiphénomène est ce qu'ils sont
prêts pas du tout mais il faut que je
termine ce que dit
ce que ça produit ça c'est une
transformation qui fait que par exemple
aujourd'hui autour de la planète
dans la stratosphère il ya des
satellites en pagaille et que ces
satellites basse et je suis venu avec
eux pour trouver la rhune gergovie
puisque finalement j'ai trianguler voilà
faut pas dire tant pis son retard et
ses satellites dont il nous sommes tous
tracés par satellite et ça ça produit
quelque chose de nouveau qui sort ce que
j'appelle la exauce ferrique de la
biosphère d'accès en dehors la biosphère
c'est ça mon tour la biosphère et c'est
dans ce contexte là qui par ailleurs
mobilise des technologies de calcul qui
ont la capacité à traiter à travers ce
qu'on appelle le calcul intensif
simultanément des milliards de données
produites par trois milliards et demi
peut être bien 4 milliards maintenant de
smartphones et smartphones y en a un en
afrique et en inde comme aux états unis
en europe et en chine
pourquoi parce que finalement c'est ce
qui nécessite le moins d'infrastructures
et donc il est très très très facile
d'implanter des réseaux de smartphones
des réseaux d'égouts ça coûte
extrêmement cher des réseaux électriques
ça coûte extrêmement cher mais des
smartphones si vous avez des petites
centrales électriques enfin des petits
générateurs de deux sources de
l'électricité photovoltaïque outre vous
pouvez déployer sa vous avez des
smartphones en amazonie dans le sahara
renée partout en fait et donc on a
peut-être 4 milliards maintenant de
smartphones qui sont tous connectés à
l'échelle de la planète et qui sont
connectés à la vitesse de la lumière
pour les cas les plus optimisées ça
change absolument tout à la dynamique de
la biosphère c'est dans ce contexte là
que se développe le storytelling du
transhumanisme qu'est ce que c'est que
les lettons humanis ce sont des gens qui
sont soutenus par google c'est ni versé
de la singularité notamment y en a
d'autres bien entendu extra obtient dont
on parlait tout à l'heure mais
et ce sont des gens qui alors il ya des
gens qui croient tout ça évidemment
qu'ils sont mais il ya des gens qui ne
croient pas ça ou qu'ils y croient je
dirais c'est totalement secondaire ils
ont surtout une stratégie industrielle
ils ont une stratégie industrielle de
prise du contrôle du processus d'examen
tease à sion parce que ce qu'on appelle
l'industrie c'est de les automatisations
voilà il ya un nouvel iphone disque est
sorti je sais pas quoi c'est un nouvel
organe exo somatiques et l'industrie
c'est ce qui produit l'exo somatisation
toujours plus vite toujours plus je
table etc et qui est en train de
détruire en fait la planète parce que
c'est une combi aujourd'hui les
conditions de cette production
automatique ne sont plus réunies sur la
planète qu'est ce qu'on fait eh bien on
réfléchit
on réfléchit vite parce qu'il faut se
dépêcher plus de 200 mètres seconde
vacances alors de 100 millions de m par
seconde ça c'est les performances de la
formation entre wall street et et la
bourse de paris
qui permet ce qu'on appelle trading
haute fréquence hft africaine titré
ligne alors il faut réfléchir en allant
plus vite que les algorithmes
c'est tout à fait possible
je vais vous dire deux mots pourquoi
c'est possible un algorithme ça peut
aller extrêmement vite ça peut aller 4
millions de fois plus vite que le
système nerveux d'un individu mais
l'individu qui pensent ça ne va pas
plus vite qu'un algorithme ça va
infiniment vite
c'est ce que je veux dire par là c'est
que ce qui va très vite dans les agrumes
chez des capacités de calcul est
extrêmement vite sur les très très très
très grande masse de données penser
c'est pas calcul c'est bifurquait
c'est une machine peut pas me choquer
dans ce sens là donc penser ça veut dire
à mon année elle est infiniment plus
vite que n'importe quel algorithmes en
bifurquant c'est changer la vision des
choses claires de lucidité non c'est
cultivait talent et notre pays c'est
sale année d'entropie à lorsque l'appel
l'année notre pays avec un a et h
c'est à dire la noesis telle qu'elle
engendre de la de l'anneau diversité est
telle qu'elle produit de la pensée donc
d'aucun pons
il faut une masse une masse critique de
cette pensée pour avoir une action dans
le monde physique
quand on voit quand on voit le cheptel
la masse
se se rende dépendant de technologie
comme certaines applications très
chronophage hook renouveau est ce que
est ce que c'est pas trop tard parce que
les gens sortent jet hardcore est ce que
jenson pas trop con ou sont pas trop
dans le déni pour se réapproprier ça
parce que pense et nous on fait notre
communauté on pense va pas dire
différemment mais on a une façon de
s'organiser qui est pour les autres
différentes
qu'est ce qu'on fait il ya plein de gens
qui pensent et plein de gens qui pensent
simplement
il ne pense pas tout le temps et
personne ne pense tout le temps
d'ailleurs yak c'est ce que dit aristote
ya que dieu qui pense tout le temps il
est là reste à 10 seul dieu peut jouir
de ce privilège d'être toujours présent
à lui-même c'est-à-dire d'être toujours
conscient de lui-même on appelle ça une
malédiction
nous nous sommes tous
exposés à
l'intermittence de la pensée au fait que
la plupart du temps nous ne pensons pas
en fait vous répétons des choses que
nous croyons on pense quand même pas
très souvent réalité même les grands
génies d'ailleurs einstein l'expliquent
ça et qu'il faut des conditions bien
spécifiques pour lui pour qu'il arrive à
passer quelque chose et ça passe
d'ailleurs par le silence pendant des
semaines et tout ça ment mais
bien sûr que c'est trop tard c'était
évident maintenant
capable d'aller infiniment plus vite
cette guerre c'est peut-être trop tard
mais en même temps c'est toujours toi
tard d'ailleurs c'est ce que des règles
légales deal à la chouette de minerve
arrive toujours trop tard la philosophie
arrive toujours trop tard la pensée avec
toujours total donc la question oui
c'est trop tard mais comment on fait que
cela ne retarde devienne une avance
alors je vais essayer de répondre
ou pratiquement et pas avec des
théorèmes ou des idées ou des
spéculations comme je viens de les
annoncer la
moi en ce moment je discute avec des
grands acteurs industriels un sou pour
le grand paris
dassault orange
vinci beaucoup de grands acteurs
industriels
européens
et ses grands acteurs industriels pour
beaucoup d'entre eux savent qu'ils sont
extraordinairement menacé
les banques sont très très très menacé
mais l'industrie est très menacée
l'industrie du bâtiment l'industrie
métallurgique et cetera
et
s'ils veulent survivre ces gens là il
faut qu'il invente quelque chose de
nouveau sinon le modèle je dirais de la
plateforme isation façon silicon valley
et mangera inévitablement que ce soit le
celui de la silicone ray ou celui de la
chine parce que la chine est en train de
développer son modèle je le connais très
bien ce modèle
ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que faire d'abord tous les
gens qui sont sérieux ils ne le disent
jamais mais tous les gens qui sont
sérieux dans ces entreprises il ya des
gens très sérieux dans cette entreprise
parce que si elles tiennent le coup
c'est parce que ce sont des gens qui
sont capables de les faire tenir savent
que le système n'est pas solvable il est
passé en vente sur plan financier il
repose sur de la monnaie de singe voilà
et qui peut s'écouler du jour au
lendemain
via les crypto monnaie autre peu importe
d'axés secondaires mais le système n'est
pas solvable
si le gembri
deuxièmement il est un super
insoutenable environnementalement
énergétiquement
démographiquement etc
troisièmement eux dans cette
soutenabilité ses acteurs ne mange pas
là sont extrêmement mal positionné
parce que pour ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure de l'europe c'est à dire que
l'europe est apparue de compréhension
toutes ces réalités là et que finalement
la paye de stratégie industrielle ni
rien et donc elle est à courir derrière
les processus d'innovation que je
considère être moi de l'innovation
négatif et à l'innovation destructrice
mais c'est l'innovation quand même et
c'est elle qui attire le business voilà
et donc ces acteurs là ces grands
acteurs-là ils savent en fait très
profondément qu'il faut changer l'ordre
des choses le problème c'est qu'une safa
comment
moi je travaille avec l'association ars
industrialis mon institut une recherche
innovation et pas mal d'acteurs parce
que nous avons un réseau mondial nous
travaillons nous sommes faisons pas de
tapage mais nous travaillons à une
beaucoup de monde dans le monde entier
avec des chercheurs avec des
mathématiciens avec des entrepôts langue
avec les logiciens des philosophes des
confitures säntis des informaticiens qui
il vient cure en plus longues et des
hackers bien entendu et nous travaillons
à
construire une nouvelle perspective
qu'est ce que c'est que cette
perspective s'est laissé la perspective
de nous c'est ce que nous appelons
l'économie de la négo croppi ou qu'on
appelle aussi l'économique contributives
alors cette réflexion sur l'économie
quand très vite et je les développer
mois alina quand j'ai découvert le
logiciel libre ya plus de vingt ans
maintenant il ya près de deux ans
et je connaissais pas le ciel des mois
vous avez peut-être entendu parler
vaguement mais j'avais jamais vu puis je
me suis retenu dans le cas où ce
computer club web a bien sûr
j'avais
du jour au lendemain je me suis retrouvé
à travailler dans une
entreprise publique donc s'appelle
l'institut national de l'audiovisuel
dans laquelle il y avait des
développeurs qui travaillait pour le
service de la recherche
il travaille en logiciels libres et donc
j'ai découvert cette organisation du
travail
j'ai découvert qu'elle reposait sur le
partage du savoir et non pas sur
l'appropriation du savoir et qu'en fait
elle reposerait sur la d prolétarisation
des individus
et là je me suis dit il se passe quelque
chose de très important alors allez pas
que ça restait extrêmement marginale
celle d'aujourd'hui c'est majoritaire
l'ours est majoritaire pas sous sa forme
accomplie quel logiciel sûrs à
proprement parler mais la logique
opsource etc s'est imposée et elle s'est
imposée dans tous les grands business
model des plateformes justement par
exemple google en est un on est une
illustration parmi bien d'autres et plus
personne dans mon industriel discutent
de la deûle à l'efficacité et de la
nécessité de ce type d'organisation
maintenant sept types d'organisation
entre en contradiction avec le modèle
industriel dominant qui restent
dominants pourquoi parce que ce type
d'organisation il produit l'année contre
pied est ce que j'appelais total en
année contre 10 ans le modèle dominant
il repose sur la production dans tropic
à partir pourquoi parce que ce qu'on
appelle
les économies d'échelle dans le domaine
de la grande industrie de masse c'est ce
qui produit inévitablement de
l'entreprise là dans le logiciel libre
par exemple dans ce type d'organisation
parce qu'il ya pas que le logiciel libre
qu'il fonctionne sur des modèles de ce
type aujourd'hui eh bien on produit de
l'année grand tropisme aux produits les
économies d'échelle mais diversifié
complexifier localisé et est très très
très organisé très robuste très
solidaires si c'est un tout autre modèle
en fait du chillou pardon bon jeu du chu
luu voilà et ce modèle là il est
eh bien il est il est soutenable il est
beaucoup plus économique il est beaucoup
plus robuste il produit l'intelligence
et non pas de la crétinisation et donc
il est ce qui permet de lutter par
ailleurs contre quoi je passe sur un
autre registre contre les effets
d'automatisation
aujourd'hui on n'arrête pas maintenant
nous bassiner avec l'intelligence
artificielle et ses légendes découvre
tout à coup un certain nombre de
questions
mais l'intelligence artificielle c'est
surtout l'algorithme isation de toute
chose qu'on appelle un petit peu
abusivement parfums thé genre artificiel
mais peu importe
cet algorithme isation elle est en train
de faire diminuer l'emploi
qui était déjà assez bas et qui va
encore diminuer sensiblement à quelle
hauteur personne ne le sait mais ce sont
des facteurs de 10 à 20 ou 30% emplois
qui sont menacés de disparition
dans les 20 années qui viennent et
le système aujourd'hui n'est pas
solvable mais si en plus il y avait 1 %
de chômeurs supplémentaires il est tout
simplement insolvable il est il et il
s'écroule je laissais serment j'ouvre
une parenthèse
dans votre organisation qui s'apparente
à un think tank à peu près c'est ça non
j'ai
j'appelle ça un lieu de recherche ont
fait des expérimentations de penser
comment vous vous anticipez comment vous
appréhendez le paramètre violence
violence
je dirais façon gustave lebon dans la
psychologie des foules
je vais en parler mais je vais finir
d'avoir ce que je sais
19h57 bernard oui mais mais je dis bien
déroulée mais idc jusqu'au bout
parce que c'est là on parle en plus des
choses fondamentales qui sont à
l'origine de la violence d'ailleurs
le système actuel dans lequel nous
sommes qui a été construit en 1933 par
keynes avec roosevelt et qui reposait
sur la valorisation de l'emploi la
redistribution de pouvoir d'achat à
travers l'emploi pour rendre solvables
les marchés de production donc les gens
puissent acheter ok de la consommation
ce système est en train de s'écrouler et
il faut pourquoi il ya vingt ans et quiz
parce que l'emploi est est en train de
régresser donc les demoiselles est en
train de s'écrouler à cause de la
fonction exponentielle
c'est la fonction qui vont en ciel est
évidemment une dimension de la chose et
même on appelle même hyper exponentielle
aujourd'hui mais
ce processus là
il si on ne répond pas à cela le système
ne peut plus se développer donc la
question qui se pose c'est de
redistribuer du pouvoir d'achat ou plus
exactement des gains de productivité par
d'autres voies que l'emploi est cette
redistribution c'est une généralisation
pour nous premièrement d'un modèle du
logiciel libre c'est à dire de
communautés de savoir qui partagent des
façons de faire et deuxièmement une
solvabilisation de les communautés de
savoir pain l'extension progressive du
régime des intermittents du spectacle à
toutes sortes d'activités qui sont pas
simplement les activités artistiques de
spectacles de cinéma de musique
tel que ça existe aujourd'hui mais des
activités qui vont produire l'année
d'entropie pourquoi est-ce qu'on donne
ce régime d'intermittence aux artistes
parce qu'ils produisent de l'année
d'entropie ou smooth
c'est parce que là il faut regarder de
près la raison pour laquelle c'est le
patronat français qui a créé ce régime
c'est parce qu'il disait on a besoin de
techniciens qui sont des singularités
qui sont pas simplement des techniciens
mais les artistes et qui sont capables
de faire des choses que personne d'autre
qu'à leur place n'est capable d'ouvrir
alors maintenant ce qui se dit en ce
moment c'est que le régime des
intermittents du spectacle ou si c'est
ça permet d'avoir des passeurs de soupe
donc ça facilite même passé détourner le
processus bien entendu comme tout et
vous détourner le livre aussi est
détournée trouvait toujours détourné
mais en revanche
le modèle de l'intermittence et la
valorisation des singularités la
prolétarisation de massaly mines et
toutes les singularités c'est ça qui
faisait péter les plombs de l'écharde
urnes et aujourd'hui on a besoin de
singularité non pas pour simplement les
cuivres psychologique des individus mais
pour l'économie parce que l'économie de
demain c'est une économie de l'année
contre pie nous sommes dans
l'anthropocène l'anthropocène c'est
l'augmentation l'entropie il faut
valoriser systémiquement maintenant que
la valorisation de l'année d'autres pays
il faut augmenter
l'année d'autres pays donc favoriser les
savoirs et donc faut repenser
complètement l'économie et ça c'est une
perspective qui intéresse tout le monde
y compris les entreprises du capitalisme
européen parce qu'elles n'ont pas le
choix ou bien un examen est un nouveau
modèle qui va être capable d'inventer
comme roosevelt et qu'heinze aux états
unis en 1933 inventer un nouveau modèle
est bien l on trouve un nouveau modèle
et elles arriveront à le négocier avec
les acteurs du monde entier ou bien ou
bien ils disparaîtront mais c'est pas
simplement elle qui disparaîtront avance
la basse on va tous oui alors justement
pourquoi la violence voilà nous savions
la violence la violence avoir c'est de
la pulsion c'est le fait qu' on devient
violent lorsque la pulsion prend le
contrôle de
de notre comportement c'est à dire que
tout ce qu'on a appris à éviter comme
expression de la pulsion reprend le
dessus voilà pour des raisons qui
peuvent arriver à tout le monde
d'ailleurs ça va arriver moi même de
faire des passages à l'acte violents et
et je pense aux erreurs de jeunesse ou
renier tous exposés ou mêmes ça peu à
peu aussi la personne la violence et la
force des faibles et commence où
s'arrête les connaissances
la violence est aujourd'hui
effectivement la grande menace sur la
sur la terre entière
parce que d'abord parce que la puissance
cumulée est absolument colossal que la
vulnérabilité des systèmes est
absolument colossal et que la souffrance
est absolument colossal et en plus il
n'y a pas d'issue en l'état actuel des
choses
par exemple les processus migratoires
dont on parle et qui vend énormément
s'aggraver en amont n'est qu'au tout
début là des grandes migrations c'est
celui d'hier ils ne peuvent que produire
d'une extrême violence si on ne produit
pas les nouveaux modèles de
développement
alors moi ce que je crois c'est que
cette violence on te la combattre non
pas par la répression
mais par la raison je fais partie des
gens qui croient à ça ce que vous allez
raisonnée quelqu'un qui à la fin aux
tripes une
épigénétiques qui le poursuit depuis des
générations et la question c'est pas les
gens qui ont faim la question c'est ce
qu'ils peuvent prendre des décisions sur
ces processus là donc par exemple en ce
moment on voit là il ya tout un débat
lancé par macro y en a eu chaud au
volant de nicosie et créera sur les deux
pour des voitures l'immigration enfin
mais la vraie question et tout le monde
le sait d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on
appelait à une époque le codéveloppement
enfin ce type de ce type de logique
cette logique elle va s'imposer pourquoi
parce que c'est pas au niveau des
individus et moi je ne crois pas je ne
crois pas que ce soit les masses qui
fasse les grands processus de
transformation pas du tout quand je peux
te couper un peu bien sûr
ce que je veux dire par là c'est que les
êtres humains ils sont
victimes sont de bipolariser ils sont
bipés la risée pas au sens aujourd'hui
on parle de la maladie bipolaire mais au
sens où gilles bercy moment mais
philosophe français dit que voilà on est
ils appellent ça inscrit sur ce qu'il
appelle la dia d'indéfini de la
tentation par exemple il parle de x man
is man c'est un industriel très connu
c'est lui qui a inventé kodak et
karmique a créé kodak c'est un
industriel très connu et très riche et
s'est suicidé ils se disent pourquoi il
s'est suicidé esman c'est parce qu'il ya
un moment donné il était polarisée par
là par la pulsion de mort là on est tous
polarisé en permanence par des par des
comportements tout à fait opposite au
positif voilà on est tous en permanence
tenté par la régression aujourd'hui on a
une société qui cultive la rénovation de
manière systémique c'est pour ça que
évidemment il ya des raisons d'être très
très dubitatif sur les capacités que
l'humanité a de s'en sortir mais
ça bien entendu faut être très
lucidement à ces choses là maintenant je
pense que moi je suis passé par beaucoup
d'expérience limites voilà des choses
très très très arabe je connais des
milieux et des mondes extrêmement dur
les chercheurs l'intérieur est ce que je
sais c'est que
il est toujours possible
de toutacoup activé chez un individu
alors peut-être qu'adolf hitler n'était
pas c'était pas possible peut-être bien
mais j'ai tous les gens que j'ai
rencontrés mois il est possible était
possible toujours d'activer quelque
chose qui était de loeb d'un seul coup
non pas de la tentation de la régulation
mais d'intermittence de l'esprit même
chez des gens qui sont supposés être
complètement crétiniser et ses jeux j'ai
parlé à même à l'époque j'habitais dans
un village en picardie à un moment donné
30 % de chômeurs mes voisins étaient
tous électeurs du front national dommage
discuter avec eux c'étaient mes voisins
donc j'ai essayé de parler avec
évidemment que c'était des électeurs du
front national était voilà c'était assez
effrayant par moments dans leurs propos
mais en même temps quand on discutait
avec elle puise une certaine rationalité
nouvelle ne s'est pas seulement ça mais
il pouvait devenir des gens achement
bien et donc et donc voilà il faut bien
en tant mieux qu'aujourd'hui on est dans
la massification
crétinisation de masse je suis le
premier à expliquer ça donc je suis tout
à fait convaincu mais après ça sert à
rien de spéculer
ce qui est important c'est d'être
capable de penser soi même une pensée
quand elle est puissante elle est
capable de ceux de se généraliser est ce
que tu es ce que vous connaissez
krishnamurthy
jamais entendu parler
je te conseille la remise de la médaille
de la paix de l'onu de krishnamurti en
1985 tu trouveras une vidéo sur le net
désolé de cette parenthèse
philosophe indien
qui
explique qu'il faut accepter les autres
certes
qu'il faut être capable de penser
c'est bien sauf que nous on tire le
constat suivant
ça ne reste que du blabla
nous voit on les voit échanger on voit
les flux d'informations voilait les
dictionnaires de censure émergé sur les
réseaux sociaux on voit tout ce
vocabulaire être supprimées on voit de
l'agressivité des gens montés et les
solutions proactives
c'est un grain de sable
quand on s'intéresse
je comprends très bien tout ça mais
après ce qu'il faut c'est être capable
de faire une description rationnelle de
ces processus tout ce que vous décrivez
là c'est l'augmentation l'entropie sur
le réseau moi je j'ai beaucoup de
travail et en ce moment d'ailleurs il ya
des tas de papiers qui sortent aux états
unis par exemple sur l'augmentation de
l'entreprise sur les réseaux sociaux ça
n'arrête plus il en sort de partout ces
banques est double c'est sa part dans
ces banques et bleu c'est trendy non
mais non c'est simplement cédé matheux
qui font des maths est qui et qui
constatent des choses et qu'ils disent
ces systèmes ils vont vers la fermeture
du système c est ce que le vit sur un
bertin enfile des cris vers 1930 il déjà
donc et donc ils sont ils conduisent
nécessairement l'effondrement donc après
mois sur madame soleil j'en ai rien à
[__] ça m'intéresse pas du tout je
fais pas de prévisions sur l'avenir je
crois pas du tout à ces machines parce
que simplement j'essaie de faire c'est
de dire voilà il y a des
analyse rationnelle qui peuvent être
produites de ce processus il faut les
produire et ensuite il est impératif il
faut faire en sorte qu'elle puisse venir
à la rencontre de position d'acteur
disons les acteurs fait pas forcément
des personnes des institutions des
groupes d des entreprises des toutes
sortes de toutes sortes de
dison de de puissance d'agir de
individuelle ou collective
il faut que sa rencontre c'est processus
voilà après bon moi de toute façon je
pense que
si on prend une
analyse sur un modèle rationnelle au
sens courant du mot rationnelle c'est à
dire où on est capables de rationaliser
au sens où les comptables sont capables
de rationner c'est-à-dire de calculer
il n'y a aucune chance que la planète
s'en sortent c'est absolument évident
maintenant
seule chose qui est importante c'est de
savoir quand thierry des systèmes un
système n'est jamais capable de calculer
sa bifurcation
jusqu'en août le goût et donc non un
cygne noir oui mais voilà merci pas tout
à fait la même chose c'est une question
plutôt de dison de statistiques mais ce
qui est important c'est les systèmes
dynamiques systèmes dynamiques ne
peuvent pas calculer leur bifurcation
elles sont improbables du point de vue
de l'intérieur du système donc ce que je
crois c'est que c'est extraordinairement
improbable
mais le possible est toujours
extrêmement improbables ce n'est que
possible c'est pas le réel après la
question j'ai de faire en sorte bomba de
créer les conditions pour que ça
devienne même si c'est extrêmement
improbable néanmoins réalisable donc
voilà c'est un sacré pour ça qu'on va
après je j'ai j'ai largement de quoi
nourrir ma mélancolie dépressive
avec toutes les données que j'analyse en
détail tous les jours donc oui bien sûr
il n'y a aucune
comment dire aucun motif de se réjouir
dans tout ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui et
on ne peut que s'inquiéter par exemple
en effet le rapport concerne les
oligarques qui ont des milliards sur
leur compte en banque de là on peut ne
peut que s'inquiéter de leur totale
pétage de plombs voilà mais il n'y a pas
il n'y a pas que ça c'est à dire que si
par exemple excusez moi une seconde si
par exemple imaginons que stanford
berkeley harvard et c'est tout l'un
toutes les les académiques comme les
appels des états unis disent on a en
beauce plus pour ce système ça marche
plus le truc
est donc et ça c'est tout à fait
possible pourquoi c'est possible
en 1088
a été créée la première université qui
est universel bologne
qui a été créée il ya mille ans un peu
plus de mille ans maintenant après il ya
eu oxford puis la sorbonne ce sens et
quelque
et puis un conflit entre le pape et
l'empereur du saint-empire romain
germanique qui s'appelait fring bardos
barbarossa complet et qu'est ce qu'il a
dit barbarossa il a dit au clair de
de
bologne à venir si de bologne je vous
donne l'autonomie totale je vous donne
un statut qui va vous protéger du
contrôle par contre toute autorité et
ses textes il a déclenché un processus
c'est ce à l'origine de l'europe moderne
c'est ce processus là pourquoi est ce
que je dis cela et on en est là c'est
pourquoi est ce que je dis cela c'est
parce que on peut très bien imaginer
moi je suis un académique comme on dit
je voyage beaucoup je te plaît aux états
unis parce qu'on m'a retiré mon visa
depuis que trump est arrivé mais je
connais très bien les états unis j'ai un
gauchisme normale et
et donc
aux états unis ce qui fait fonctionner
il ya évidemment plein de gens corrompus
dans le monde académique mais ce qui
fait fonctionner les académiques c'est
pas le pognon c'est les maths pour les
mathématiciens c'est le vivant pour les
biologistes c'est les technologies
digitales pour les conducteurs scientist
et ses acteurs et un moment donné par
ailleurs voilà la grande communauté par
exemple où il ya eu quinze mille
chercheurs 15 1364 chercheurs qui ont
publié une alerte il ya deux mois
maintenant le 13 novembre de l'année
dernière en disant c'est notre dernier
avertissement
en 2012 j'ai eu 22 chercheurs très connu
aux états unis qui ont développé et tous
ces gens là sont en train de se alors
ils sont blacklistés maintenant par
trump aujourd'hui les universitaires qui
contribue à montrer l'évidence du
changement climatique extras sont
considérés comme mauvais citoyens et ils
sont tu sais pourquoi je veux pas dire
persécutés mais voilà ils sont ils sont
harcelés disons pas jusqu'en
bas j'ai décidé sur pourquoi oui mais on
t'écoute
c'est la lutte contre ces la
crétinisation de là c'est à dire ça
passe par là et voilà c'est le déni moi
j'appelle ça le déni j'écris un livre
là-dessus qu'ils s'appellent dans la
description ou voilà nous arrive
l'organisation industrielle du déni qui
passe par des tas de stratégie mais il
n'empêche que tous ces gens là sans sans
enjeu toutes ces entreprises par exemple
ces cas là ne peuvent pas fonctionner
donc voilà tout ça peut changer après
quel est le niveau ii de probabilité du
changement ça m'est égal ce qui
m'intéresse c'est ce qui est peu
probable mois le trop bas mais je m'en
fous complètement
on arrive ça fait joli n'aurait guère
qu'on discute
mais c'est pas de papoter on essaie dé
changer
on pose toujours la même question à la
fin de notre émission qui et c'est pas
une question s'est laissé un conseil
pour les jeunes les jeunes générations
je vais te lire quelques questions qui
passent sur l'écran là tu choisiras ce
que de ce que tu lui réponds mais à la
fin il faut finir sur un conseil pour
les jeunes générations jeu désolé
d'imposer un temps mais on essaie comme
ça il est 19h15 sept minutes alors
première question où vous voyez de
l'espoir pour l'interrogation à qui
s'adresse la philosophe point
d'interrogation économie de la
connaissance point d'interrogation
économie de base basée sur les
ressources pour d'interrogation comment
expliquer l'explosion des thèses
conspirationnistes point d'interrogation
et après ça c'est un truc entre nous on
a une petite coupure internet ça a sauté
à 2 2 petites secondes et vous inquiétez
par henry au plomb dans la vidéo en
intégralité sur notre site internet inge
review.com bernard c'est à toi il est
19h15 je te laisse gérer cette minute je
te ferai un signe quand il en reste un
que deux d'accord mais moi j'ai pas
savoir répondre à cet exercice choisi ce
que tu tu reviendras parce que c'était
trop court alors
il y avait une question sur l'économie
de la connaissance
ça c'est intéressant
qui est ce que dans cette équation
économie de la connaissance ou industrie
de la connaissance
c'était
le mec qui dirigeait la comment il
s'appelait qu'il est l angleterre à une
époque tony blair a été lancée dans star
trek qui avait dit oui mais tony blair
avait dit voilà c'était d'ailleurs
contre les financements dans
l'agriculture française notamment qui
disait ça disait voilà il faut
développer une industrie de la
connaissance et a été de foot l'argent
en l'air non dans l'agriculture ou je ne
sais quoi
avant de l'industrie de la connaissance
par la société de l'information
je pense qu'il faut réfléchir à ce que
veulent dire ces expressions
société de l'information
l'industrie de la connaissance
si j'avais plus que 7 minutes j'aurais
un petit peu développé est ce que c'est
que la théorie de l'information toute la
société de l'information c'est ce qui
met en oeuvre la théorie de
l'information de claude shannon est ce
que je suis en train d'écrire les vosges
et c'est de montrer que cette théorie
est inconsistante
que l'information s'est pas du tout ce
que dit chan ou plus exactement ce que
dit shannon s'est il décrit lui la
l'anthropisation par l'information c'est
à dire la destruction justement des
capacités penser des connaissances et
des savoirs alors qu'est ce que c'est
que la connaissance
depuis
40 50 ans en amérique du nord beaucoup
d'ailleurs en californie pas seulement
également un mighty ou ailleurs mais
c'est surtout en californie on a
développé les sciences cognitives en dix
ans la connaissance et de la cognition
et donc on va étudier
la connaissance pour développer une
industrie de la connaissance à travers
des technologies de la connaissance qui
sont des machines computationnelle et on
a dit la connaissance et de la formation
traitables par des algorithmes gtr
calculable on a confondu d'abord la
théorie de l'information avec la
biologie en organisant n'échange pas de
la formation en échange des molécules
c'est pas du tout la même chose
la formation c'est entre guillemets
soi-disant immatériel des molécules
c'est tout à fait matériel et moi je
travaille et que d une groupe de
mathématiciens spécialisée en biologie
dont le responsable s'appelle giuseppe
luongo où ils montrent que ce concept
d'information est absolument pas revu
sans le pas du tout dépit génétique si
bien entendu
alors
pourquoi est-ce que je parle de tout
cela c'est parce que ce que je voudrais
dire puisque la question c'est de aussi
de parler de donner des conseils aux
générations qui viennent
il faut remettre en question tout ces
trucs théorie de l'information société
de la formation industrie de la
connaissance d'abord parce que la
connaissance est pas de la cognition ce
que les américains je parle des sciences
cognitives erika d'appel la commission
c'est ce qui leur fait dire que un
missile balistique
donc la cybernétique appliquée aux armes
et aux armes aériennes
un épi de maïs ou un tournesol
une limace est un être humain de toute
façon ça produit de la cognition parce
que ça produit deux des boucles de
rétroaction 101 cybernétique
ça c'est une chose la connaissance est
tout à fait autre chose la connaissance
c'est quelque chose d'avoir qui se
trouvent sur des supports artificielle
et qui se transmet de génération en
génération pour engendrer quoi de
l'année nos tropiques précisément c'est
à dire quelque chose qui n'est pas
calculé par des modèles computationnelle
lequel le calcul ne peut que traiter des
processus entre pikine pas il ne peut
pas produire de l'année contre pied on
peut calculer pour produire une entropie
par jean sébastien bach fait des calculs
en musique et ses acteurs mais il ya
quelque chose qui vient toujours ajouter
2 l'incalculable est d'ailleurs bac
appelle ça dieu parce que l'huile pour
ce que c'est dieu qui lui donne cette
puissance voilà il fait ça pour les les
les offices religieux tous les dimanches
13 me du protestant alors aujourd'hui ce
qu'il faut c'est repenser en profondeur
ce que c'est que le savoir est ce que
c'est que le savoir c'est ce qu'on a
perdu savoir c'est ce qui donne de la
saveur
c'est sapide de sa pereire en latin
savoureux et le savoir c'est ce qui est
aujourd'hui je vais être requis dans la
lutte contre l'entrepôt scène de plus en
plus comme étanche qui n'est pas produit
par des algorithmes et standardisé mais
qui produit par du génie humain et ce
génie humain c'est ce qui doit devoir
faire face aux défis de l'anthropocène à
ce que disent ces quinze mille trois
cent soixante quatre chercheurs à savoir
que voilà toutes les courbes son tour
dans le rouge et qu'il faut extrêmement
rapidement changer la trajectoire ça
c'est tout à fait possible la jeunesse
peut se mobiliser pour ça elle en a
l'énergie et je pense que les problèmes
sont en train de mûrir donc il faut
qu'elle s'en empare et qu'elle comprenne
bien que ce qui est très important
demain c'est de créer des communautés de
savoir c'est pour ça qu'on est hélas aux
logiciels libres et wacker ce sont des
communautés de savoir
mais il faut savoir que le savoir
c'est aussi le football c'est la cuisine
c'est toutes sortes de choses de ce
genre c'est de savoir vivre et savoir
faire et ça c'est l'économie de demain
bernard stiegler merci avec plaisir